[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
too
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm chris wilson from grinding gear
games welcome to our live stream and
thanks so much for joining us today
our team had a lot of fun putting
together path of exile's 315 expansion
and we've got a lot to share with you
today's live stream is a busy one
we'll start by revealing the details of
this expansion's new challenge league
then we'll show you how this expansion
is going to dramatically shake up path
of exile's metagame in a big way
thirdly we'll talk about our plans to
make path of exxon more challenging
restoring some of the adrenaline and
terror that you may recall from the good
old days of closed beta
next up we're going to talk about path
of exile royale the 100 player battle
royale mode that we experimented with
back in 2018
we'll be launching a restored and
revamped version of real today
once our question and answer session
with ziggy d has concluded
and this event will run over the weekend
anyway there's a lot to discuss so let's
get started with the trailer for path of
exile's next expansion
many centuries ago our people travel to
this accursed continent
we return to reclaim our lost
relics but rayclast grips its secrets
tightly
we must wrench them from its grasp
[Music]
you no violently we know trade
retrieve our relics and we'll strike a
deal
[Music]
we will follow the path of our forebears
to discover their unknown fate
[Music]
so
they wait shrouded in darkness
for one who may finally challenge them
wealth and power will be yours
should you survive our expedition
all right i've got a lot to tell you
about let's start with the expedition
league itself
long ago calgary explorers came to
rayclast in the hope of colonizing it
rayklus did what it does best and they
never returned
in the expedition league you will meet a
group of calgarians who have set out on
an expedition to investigate the fate of
their ancestors
and recover special ruined artifacts
they left behind
the ancient calgarians underestimated
the dangers of rayclust and this new
expedition is no exception
they need your help to protect them from
the undead that rise at their expedition
sites
as you travel through rayclast you'll
encounter the calgarians at sites they
believe their ancestors attempted to
settle in the past
by the time you get there they will have
marked the site with signs indicating
where chests are buried
holes indicating where their ancestors
lie and will have possibly unearthed
some remnants of past calgary and
settlement
due to the unique nature of reclass the
calgarians have found that the most
effective way to excavate these sites is
with explosives
and that's where you come in you'll
place a chain of explosives across the
expedition site
carefully planning what each blast is
going to unearth
once you push the plunger any undead
freed by the explosions rise from the
ground and the slaughter begins
some of these fall on calgar are more
difficult and rewarding than others
and have been indicated with special
markets
once you have defeated the army of
undead you're free to open all of the
chests you understand claim your rewards
it's up to you to decide where to place
the chain of explosives to maximize your
gains
do you unearth a lot of monsters do you
unearth more special monsters
or do you go for the chests and try to
avoid combat
the ancient kalgooran explorers built
structures on rayclust and you may
encounter remnants of these at
excavation sites
these remnants have various modifiers on
them that when destroyed
apply to monsters and chests unearthed
from that explosion onwards
remnants greatly increase drops but have
some very difficult modifiers like
immune to physical damage
you'll need to be very careful with your
decision of which remnants to chain your
explosives through as they substantially
ramp up the difficulty and rewards of
the encounters
speaking of rewards there's a lot of
cool stuff to find
alongside valuable equipment and
currency items are calgary artifacts and
log books which we'll talk about soon
the calgarian traders have made this
expedition to rayclast in order to
recover their ruined artifacts
there are many different types of
artifacts and each of the calgarians is
interested in a different set of them
with a unique way they want to trade
them from you for this expansion we
really wanted to play with the idea of
having nbcs that want to trade with you
in different ways
so we have themed their behaviors around
the concepts of gambling
bartering upselling and exchanging let's
meet the calgarians
tuyin is a mercurial trader who
maintains a positive outlook as long as
he can but if you cross a line his
temper changes quickly
huion offers you items with unreasonably
high prices but he's happy to haggle
you can always buy the item at the price
he's offering but if you offer a lower
price he
might accept it counteroffer or withdraw
the item entirely if he is offended by
your lobel
he also occasionally sells currency
items so it's worthwhile keeping some of
the artifacts he's looking for
on hand just in case you see an
opportunity
rog is an average man pushed into
rayclast's dangers
he's helpful concerned and a bit fearful
he is very happy for you to do the
fighting so that he can stay safe on the
sidelines
he loves making deals and trying to
upsell you
if you buy one of the items that brogg
offers he'll try to offer you a more
complex deal where he improves the item
via crafting
if you accept this deal he'll try to
upsell you again and again
until you eventually walk away with your
purchase if you can't afford one of
these incremental upgrades you can leave
and come back later with enough ruined
artifacts to cover the cost
because you don't get to supply your own
starter item for this process
and have to select an item with promise
from the range that he offers
his incremental crafting upgrades are
priced rather cheaply
gwenin is a cynical gambler who claims
that luck depends on how hard you
believe
so you really need to convince yourself
that you're going to get that headhunter
if you don't it's your fault gwenin
shows you a set of base types with
unknown properties
when you gamble by buying one you'll
receive a random item of that base type
back
it could easily be a random magic item
that you have no use for
but can sometimes be a valuable rare or
unique item
it's probably best to prioritize
gambling on base types that are most
relevant to your character
once you have exhausted all the items
that interest you it's possible to use a
specific new currency item to re-roll
the gamble window to a set of new items
of your current level
sometimes a base type shows up that is a
lot more expensive than it would
otherwise be
and gambling on this item has a higher
expected value than normal
you're taking the risk though that it
could still be junk
dannig warrior skuld is the heart of the
expedition its brave leader and
lawmaster
danig is interested in specific types of
ruined artifacts and wants to trade
these from you for a variety of options
such as currency that lets you reroll
vendor inventories
log books or artifacts that other
calgarian traders are looking for
you can talk to the traders in the wild
in town or in your hideout
they grant you access to your expedition
locker which is like the heist locker a
lockbox for league specific items
which can be accessed in all three
places also we're adding the affinity
system to these lockers
among the many relics of the ancient
calgarians you might find that their
expedition sites are logbooks
these ancient books chronicle the
locations that their ancestors visited
in their exploration of rayclust
a log book item can be rolled to have a
set of explicit mods like an end game
map
each location within the logbook has its
own implicit mods
as well as a theme that controls what
types of remnants can be found there
talk to danaik in your hideout and give
him a logbook you have found to go on an
expedition to one of the locations it
describes
these are all exotic places that no
exiles have ever traveled to before
just like how a blighted map was one
giant light encounter with no natural
monsters
the expedition you go on from a log book
is one giant expedition
[Music]
expeditions from logbooks are not only
different because of their large size
but because there are special objects
that you can interact with using
explosives
for example trees that contain monsters
or items passageways that reveal chests
or bosses and so on
speaking of bosses there are some
formidable ones for you to seek out and
a set of valuable new unique items and
base types that can only come from
expedition content
the kalgooran people are not from
rayqlast so the items do not have the
same defensive properties that ours do
instead of armor evasion and energy
shield they have ward
this new base type is a pair of boots
that grants ward and can get mods that
improve it
the way that ward works is that you have
a certain amount of it and that amount
is fully deducted from the first
incoming hits that you receive
your ward is then disabled and takes
five seconds to re-enable
at that point the next hit you receive
is substantially mitigated in the same
way
it's quite a different style of
defensive property and works very well
in conjunction with systems like evasion
block or dodge
as the undead enemies you unearth in
expedition encounters are fallen
calgorian explorers
they also have a ward rather than
traditional defenses
this unique helmet allows you to go all
in with ward as a defensive option for
your character
it causes all increases to energy shield
to affect your ward instead
grants you a bunch of ward and helps it
recover faster
this other unique helmet is also on a
new base type that grants ward instead
of other defense types but its
properties don't interact with ward
instead it prevents you from dealing
critical strikes and grants you battle
mage
which had spell damage equals the damage
of your main hand weapon
the new base types and uniques i showed
you here are just some of the ones
you'll be able to discover when you play
next week
so that's the expedition league each of
the developers i have spoken to has
liked a different aspect of it
but i have really personally been
enjoying the different trade mechanics
offered by the calgary nbc's
the gamble window takes me back 20 years
on a nostalgic trip
and tuins haggling manages to capture
the intense feeling i get when
negotiating
and anyone who really knows me knows how
much i love negotiating
this expansion also promises to
massively shake up the path of exile
metagame
and we're doing that by introducing new
gems lots and lots of new gems
for quite a while now the way we have
approached new skills in path of excel
expansions is to make a bunch of gems
themed around an entirely new build or
dramatically augmenting a few existing
builds
the blood skills in the ultimatum
expansion are a good example of this
while this approach is great in terms of
creating interesting new builds
it doesn't always affect every character
game wide in order to achieve this big
meta game shaker
we've come up with a crazy idea for the
expedition expansion
adding a gigantic pile of new gems at
once spread among as many different play
styles as possible
each of these gems can of course be used
by many different classes but we use the
list of 19 ascendancy classes for
inspiration when planning these gems
our goal here is that regardless of
which build you're playing there will be
new gems that you can add to your
character
let's go through the 19 new skill and
support gems
[Music]
the earthbreaker support gem can be
linked to any slam skill
upon use it summons an ancestor totem
that uses that slam on your behalf
in this example we've created a build
that summons multiple ancestor totems
that each wield tectonic slam
as you can see this build covers a large
area in fiery death while you get to
stay out of harm's way
this is a powerful option for chieftains
in particular due to the various totem
bonuses available on their ascendancy
passive tree
adapts players will also be wondering if
the earthbreaker support allows you to
create leap slamming totems and the
answer is
absolutely
as with other ancestor tones the
earthbreaker support also provides a
buff to you granting some increased area
of effect with melee skills
rage vortex provides a new way to
consume your rage unleashing a whirling
vortex that rapidly hits enemies within
its range
it gains damage and area of effect based
on how much rage was sacrificed
the vortex slows down when enemies
survive being hit by it causing it to
deal intense damage to tough targets
while you can only have one rage vortex
active at a time characters such as
berserkers who are able to generate a
lot of rage quickly will find it a great
way to augment their damage outward
bone shatter strikes your enemies with a
forceful blow if an enemy is stunned by
this attack a powerful shock wave is
released
the area of effect of the shock wave is
determined by the duration of the stun
you inflicted
each time you use bone shatter against
an enemy you take physical damage
yourself
and gain a trauma stack the more stacks
you have the more damage bone shadow
will deal to both you
and your enemies this self-damage
mechanic makes the juggernaut the ideal
class for the skill
because they have easy access to lots of
armor to mitigate the downside
also the juggernaut has ascendancy
passives that grant increased stun
duration which help make sure the shock
wave is as large as possible
defiance banner is a new purely
defensive banner skill
while you carry the defiance banner it
increases the armor and evasion of
nearby allies while reducing the
critical strike chance of nearby enemies
it also gains stages while carried near
enemies and can be placed on the ground
to enhance its effects
when the defiance banner is placed it
inflicts a taunt on enemies for a
duration based on the number of stages
the banner had accumulated while it was
carried
enemies affected by this torn also deal
less damage to all targets
the next new skill is shield crush which
swipes your shield towards enemies and
sends out forceful waves of damage based
on the stats of your shield
these waves can shotgun enemies with up
to two hits at once
so while shield crush is great against
groups it's also effective against
single targets and can be used alongside
shield charge and spectral shield throw
we've improved both of these skills so
that the overall aggressive shield build
is more powerful
the new behead support gem can only
support strike skills and is basically
like a mini headhunter
when a supported strike kills a rare
enemy you'll steal one of its modifiers
obviously this gem can't be as crazy as
the full headhunter experience so it
comes with some restrictions
stolen modifiers can persist for 20
seconds and slaying another rare enemy
will replace the modifier you have
active
the behead support gem also grants you
more damage against enemies on low life
in conjunction with the slayer's bane of
legends ascendancy passing this bonus
really embraces the execution theme with
the head support
storm rain is a new bose skill that
fires arrows that stick into the ground
these arrows periodically pulse with
lightning damage that arcs to nearby
arrows
this skill works very well with multiple
projectiles because you can quickly set
up a large patch of lightning death
existing ballista skills and path of
exile pick their own targets like sentry
guns do
they'll start shooting immediately and
will generally target the closest
enemies
while this behavior is usually great
sometimes you want fine control over
what your ballistas will fire
at the focus ballista support gym causes
your ballistas to pick the same targets
as you
and they will only fire when you fire
your own ranged weapon
it also makes the ballistas fire a lot
faster than they otherwise would
this support gem allows you to
effectively focus fire on specific
enemies such as bosses
explosive concoction is quite a novel
skill it introduces several new concepts
that haven't been explored with skills
before
here you can see the pathfinder throwing
an explosive projectile at monsters
firstly you may notice that the
pathfinder isn't holding any weapons
this is because explosive concoction is
the very first range skill that can
and must be used unarmed it's also the
first skill that directly interacts with
the benefits provided by your flasks
when you throw your explosive concoction
onto a targeted area it deals fire
damage and uses available charges from
your ruby sapphire and topaz flasks
to grant bonuses based on what flask
charges were used
the skill still works even if you don't
have the appropriate flasks or charges
to consume
but correctly managing your flash setup
can greatly enhance the power of this
skill
what we really love about this gem is
that it brings to life the idea of
throwing your flasks at enemies and
having them explode
in conjunction with the flask focused
benefits provided by the pathfinder's
ascendancy passive skills
we're really excited to see what new
playstyles are enabled by this gem
this is the ambush skill it teleports
you up to an enemy
blinds them and exerts your next
one-handed melee attack
this exerted attack has a high critical
strike chance and multiplier
in addition to this helping your
assassinations you can also use ambush
to quickly re-engage targets after
dashing away
voltaxic burst grants a buff that counts
down to zero triggering a burst of
lightning damage around you with a
portion of that damage converted to
chaos damage
enemies slain by your voltaxic bursts
will also explode dealing chaos damage
around them based on their maximum life
you can stack up many vortaxic bursts on
yourself at the same time
consider using duration modifiers to
modify the timing of the explosion
so that you can cast the skill from
safety and then move into a strategic
position before it explodes
when you use blade trap you throw out a
mechanical device with two copies of
your weapon attached
these blades spin rapidly in a circle a
set number of times
dealing damage to anything they pass
through when dual wielding the trap
rotates faster but deals damage based on
both weapons
because it's a trap blade trap behaves a
little differently to other attack
skills by operating independently of
your attack speed
this means you'll have some interesting
itemization choices to make in focusing
more on damage modifiers rather than the
typical focus of maximizing attack speed
summon reaper creates a single powerful
minion that uses fast melee physical
attacks which cause bleeding
while the reaper is active you can use
the skill again to direct the reaper to
a specific location
dealing a powerful attack along its path
the reaper wants to be your only minion
it reduces the life and damage of your
other minions and will consume them to
heal itself and gain damage and speed
buffs
when designing this new skill for the
necromancer we wanted to explore the
idea of having a single ultimate minion
while there were ways to somewhat
achieve this before the reaper is quite
different in its abilities and
interactions with other minions
it also feels much more active and
directly under your control
one quick note though the reaper will
absolutely eat your animated guardian if
you're not careful
forbidden right is a powerful new spell
that fires an exploding chaos projectile
at a targeted area
it also targets the selection of enemies
in an area around the player's location
and fires projectiles at them too but be
careful forbidden right also inflicts
damage on you
and cast if you can find a clever way to
mitigate this harmful downside
you'll have devastating and widespread
damage at your fingertips
the eye of winter is a large projectile
that fires out a barrage of cold
projectiles in the spiral formation as
it travels
when it reaches its maximum distance or
collides with the terrain
it explodes firing out even more
projectiles in the spiral
this type of skill is one we've been
wanting to bring to path of exile for a
long time
and we felt this new collection of
skills was the perfect place to showcase
it
this inquisitor is using the new battle
mage's cry skill which taunts nearby
enemies and exerts your subsequent
attacks
causing them to trigger a linked spell
on your next melee hit
here you can see the player taunting
enemies with battle mage's cry and using
consecrated path to teleport to enemies
the slam is exerted triggering firestorm
to rain down on those enemies
in order to assist with scaling both
attack and spell damage
the buff this warcry provides that your
spell damage apply to your attacks this
property is usually only available on
wands and certain unique items
mana bond is a somewhat unusual gem and
that its source of power relies on your
current mana
upon use it creates a rune that explodes
at a location you're targeting
this explosion can either deal more
damage or cover a larger area depending
on the state of your mana
the more mana that's missing from your
mana pool the more damage mana bond will
deal as it converts a percentage of your
missing mana into added lightning damage
the more full your monopole is the more
area the explosion will cover
this means that being adept at managing
your mana pool becomes highly
advantageous
for example having slightly higher mana
while clearing a map provides greater
clear speed
when fighting tougher enemies having a
lower current runner amount is better
absolution has been designed for
guardians as a spell version of
dominating blow
absolution deals a damaging shock wave
in a targeted area
when it kills an enemy it summons the
sentinel of absolution which also deals
damage by casting absolution itself
the sentinels also periodically cast a
larger version of absolution on the
cooldown
while the sentinel's version of
absolution can't summon even more
minions
they are a powerful army to fight
against
spectral helix throws a spectral copy of
your melee weapon which spirals outwards
from you
dealing damage to any enemies it passes
through
the design of the skill achieves what we
always wanted val's spectral throw to be
we thought it was a really fun idea for
a skill but because of the limitations
caused by the soul gathering
requirements of vowel skills
it wasn't possible to use vowel spectral
throw as a primary skill
now that spectral helix can live up to
this purpose we've reworked vel's
spectral throw
which will reveal closer to release one
of the other issues that vilespectral
throw had was that it didn't work very
well
in indoors areas however spectral helix
improves upon this as the projectiles
that spiral outwards can also bounce off
of walls and proceed to hit enemies
rather than simply disappearing upon
collision
over the last few years path of exile
has really suffered from player power
creep
as a consequence of trying to make
compelling content each expansion we
release either gives players more axes
on which to improve their character
more effective skills to use or ways to
craft better and more powerful items
measuring from closed beta to now this
expedition expansion is our 30th path of
exile release
the amount of power creep varies per
release of course with systems like
ascendancy classes providing what like
20 30 40 power creep at once
like with compound interest it would
only take percent more player power per
expansion from new items
crafting character systems item
acquisition opportunities
and new skills for player power to grow
tenfold since the game has been out
and tenfold is roughly what we measure
the increase in player power to be
we may nerf the most out of hand cases
every launch but we're only reducing
them back down to close to the new
baseline
the average path of exile character gets
more and more powerful
while we do occasionally add new endgame
challenges that are appropriate for the
current power level of top characters
the rest of the game just becomes
relatively easier and easier
some games handle this by just endlessly
and exponentially scaling monster life
and damage to counteract player power
growth
eventually the numbers get too large and
you need to crunch them all down again
this is a really cheap approach it makes
the game feel like a treadmill where the
developers are just turning a knob as
they hand you new power
keeping you in the same place forever we
don't want to treat path of excel like
that and hence our solutions are more
complicated
at the same time one of the issues is
that players will always pick the most
powerful way of interacting with any
game system
even when that's not actually fun to
play this leads to behaviors like flask
piano or the way that everyone just
picks support gems that basically add
pure damage
as game designers it is our
responsibility to make sure that the
most powerful behaviors are also the
most fun to engage with
with that in mind the balance changes
that we are making in expedition are
far-reaching and are going to affect
almost all characters our goal is not to
just nerf specific builds but to improve
the game
it's challenge and to make sure that
people want to pick fun build choices
[Music]
anyone who played path of exile during
its closed beta 9 years ago can attest
to how challenging the campaign was to
play through early monsters were
dangerous and terrifying
able to kill a character in a few
seconds of inattention players feared
going into the ship graveyard cave
because of the flicker strike ghosts
they were careful around rowers because
a couple of unlucky charges could
outright kill them
trying to kill a goatman shaman while he
had molten shell up was a pretty
terrible idea
nowadays however the game is a lot
easier we added level 2 and 4 support
gems without increasing the difficulty
of the game to compensate at all
modern league mechanics shower the
player in rare items from early levels
and we didn't make the game any harder
in response in fact
it's very interesting to compare the
difficulty of league content with that
of the base game
for a few years now we've been shipping
difficult leagues where monster life and
damage values are a lot higher than the
regular monsters that players fight
between those league encounters
players enjoy league content because
it's challenging they also told us they
really enjoyed the path of xl2 demo at
exilcon and it was tuned to be almost
punitive in terms of difficulty
one thing we learned from building that
demo was that it's okay for some
monsters to be able to run twenty to
forty percent faster than the player
in path of exile one's first tax there
isn't a single monster that moves faster
than the player's default movement speed
we are rebalancing the campaign to be
challenging so far we have focused
mostly on act one but with each coming
expansion we'll be extending this
further
our plan is that within a year or so
we'll have reviewed or touched every
single monster in the game
while this additional challenge probably
won't stop our most skilled players
easily dominating the campaign or
running through it to get to maps
quickly
it will mean that players who engage
with the content will find a consistent
difficulty level between league content
and regular content
it's worth noting that the behavioral
and balance changes to monsters will
definitely affect their map versions
[Music]
for quite some time path of exile
players and developers have been keen
for a big rework to its flask system
in the end game flasks grant really
powerful buffs for a number of seconds
after use
and these buffs allow the player to kill
monsters quickly filling the flasks up
so they can be used as soon as they run
out
with five such flasks equipped the
correct behavior was to spam the one to
five keys repeatedly
to keep all the flasks constantly up
without any downsides this flask piano
playstyle was popular enough that
players were improvising devices to hit
all of those keys at once
spamming the same set of keys repeatedly
to get a powerful set of buffs that
rival the power you get from your entire
set of equipped items
is not a fun game mechanic it's
unbalanced and certainly isn't nice on
your wrist
it prevents us from balancing the game
well for players who aren't smashing
their keyboard constantly and seriously
restricts the design space we can use on
flasks
in addition certain unique flasks
completely outclass other ones in terms
of raw damage output
it was pretty clear to us that path of
exile would be a lot better if we did
some serious work on flasks to make sure
that their incentives were aligned with
fun
rather than with spamming blindly most
utility flasks and unique flasks have
been rebalanced
expect a lot less permanent power from
flasks
plus that provide raw defense or raw
power are the ones with the biggest
nerfs
some flasks have been selectively buffed
a bit if they were underpowered or less
popular
in the expedition expansion there are
now three ways that you can use flasks
you can either continue to use the
rebalanced ones the traditional way
or you can apply one of the two new
types of currency items your flasks
the instilling orb and in kindling orb
drop as part of the regular drop pool
from regular monsters and chests
the instilling orb will cause a flask to
be used automatically
upon a specific condition being met for
example when its charges become full or
when you become affected by ignite
this means that in the cases where you
would previously want to time a specific
flask usage
you can now rely on it happening
automatically with the only trade-off
being that it may consume charges that
you otherwise wouldn't intend it to
there are a variety of different
conditions and a random one is enchanted
onto your flask overwriting the others
each time you use an instilling orb on
it
the unkindling orb prevents utility
flasks from gaining charges while active
but provides a big boost to their effect
duration or various ways they interact
with their charges
there are various different types of
boosts so you can use more orbs to
re-roll for the one that you want
when a flask removes a curse it no
longer applies a period of immunity to
curses blasts that remove ailments now
only provide a period of immunity to the
helmet if they actually removed it
so if you get ignited use a dowsing
flask to remove the ignite and to gain
immunity for a while
you can't spam the flask before you're
ignited to be permanently immune
if you want permanent mitigation of
elements there are other options for
your build
note that we have rebalanced element
mitigation in general so there aren't a
few options that completely outclass the
rest
monster density and path of exile gets a
lot higher as you play through the game
when we initially balanced flash charge
generation a decade ago
we did not anticipate the levels of
monster density we would reach by 2021.
monsters in acts 6 through 10 now
generate fewer flash charges and
monsters and maps generate even fewer
still
so now there's a lot more strategy
involved with flask use flasks don't get
as many charges
so are a little harder to constantly
spam and aren't designed to provide such
a powerful slew of permanent buffs
but you can control which provide larger
than normal effects and which are
triggered automatically as part of your
build
we have reworked existing flasks such as
basalt and aquamarine flasks and have
introduced new corundum and gold flasks
for a while now we have been concerned
with a power gap between support gems
there are gems that grant huge
multiplicative damage bonuses and there
are gems that do a bunch of stuff you
don't really care about
when you're building a character by far
the correct choice is just to stack on
all the multiplicative damage bonuses
and ignore all the interesting utility
support gems
because their opportunity cost is just
too high
we are reducing the damage bonuses on
the support gems that are clearly just
about huge damage boosts
and trying to give them impactful and
appropriate downsides for example
the control destruction support gem now
penalizes critical strikes
multiplicatively
overall this works out to a total of
somewhere around 20
potentially as high as 40 percent damage
reduction for a character using a fully
six-length skill
with entirely damaged support gems
there's much less impact for characters
that use utility support gems or those
who didn't have a six link setup
this achieves two goals for us firstly
the gap between good and bad support
gems has been narrowed creating more
interesting build opportunities
secondly player damage output in the
endgame is reduced which is a goal for
this balance pass
as i mentioned we want to iteratively
restore challenge to path of exile
it's worth clarifying that we haven't
buffed unused utility support gems as
part of this balance pass
it's fully intentional that it's a
reduction of power for the most damaging
ones
when we're designing skills for path of
exile the mana cost of the skill is a
mechanism to allow us to have larger
impactful effects
bigger skills should cost more money to
cast unfortunately this entire mechanism
is currently bypassed by triggering
skills as it skips their mana costs
this basically means that we can't
design really powerful spells
in 315 triggering skills through support
gems will require paying their money
cost
in fact sometimes it now costs more than
casting the gem by hand
thankfully though this isn't very hard
with well-constructed characters
certain support gems that were
originally disabled from supporting
triggered skills like arcane surge can
now be used to support them
builds that use triggered skills are
some of the most interesting characters
in path of excel
and they are often the best
representation of the craziness that our
character customization system allows
we're confident that they are just as
powerful as before but we now have more
interesting design space to explore with
future skills
now let's talk about movement skills as
you know most interaction with monster
behavior is essentially bypassed if
you're using an extremely effective
movement skill
this is okay if you're specialized
deeply into customizing that skill
but is currently the default state for
any character if you use flame dash
smoke mine or dash without any further
investment
these skills have been rebalanced to be
more in line with other movement skills
these are not huge numeric nerfs but do
mean that there is scope for improving
the performance of the skills by
specializing around them
there are many other balance changes in
315 which you can read about in the
balanced manifesto and patch notes next
week
to be honest there are a lot of nerfs
here we completely understand that this
level of change will make some people
nervous
but it's time we start actively
combating power creep and fixing game
systems that haven't been working the
way we intended them to
i think that the metagame of expedition
is going to be fascinating
the reduction of overall player power
combined with all of the opportunities
from the new skills and flask system
changes
should create entirely new sets of
builds that we haven't previously seen
you guys are always surprising us with
what you do and we can't wait to see
what you come up with here
so back in early 2018 there was a trend
where every online game was releasing a
battle royale mode and getting a lot of
good press in the process
we had a running joke in the office that
our fast development speed meant that we
could probably add a battle royale mode
to path of exile in one day of
development
as april fool's day approached we tried
to do exactly that
we pulled a few developers together and
asked them to spend no more than one
workday each on their contributions to
this new mode
on april 1 2018 we launched path of
exile royale
gold buddy
it was a quick and dirty job so he only
left the game mode turned on for a
couple of days
it went pretty well considering it had
no custom balance whatsoever
oh my god i'm getting destroyed
after april 1st we turned the mode off
and forgot all about it
but the community did not forget in fact
they've been quite keen to remember it
constantly and to urge us to bring it
back
but that wouldn't be easy as to actually
make it a decent experience would
require a lot of custom balance
play testing and feature implementation
work a few months ago we decided to do
exactly that
path of xor royale will return today in
fact immediately after the qa section of
this live stream
we're going to run it for the weekend as
a test and then turn it on every weekend
for a while starting the week after
expeditions launch
we'll patch up between weekends with
balanced tweaks and if it's popular over
the long term
new features we have no idea what the
long-term viability of this game mode is
going to be like so we'll run it for
this league and then assess where things
stand
our initial version of real from 2018
used path of exile's default passive
skill tree
which didn't have interesting options
for characters that rarely got to level
10.
it also used all of our skill gems and
unique items as is
where many of the interesting ones were
way too high level for these super low
level characters to ever find
we've made a completely new royal
specific passive skill tree that has
everything you need to quickly adapt
your character for high speed pvp combat
it features approximately 90 new custom
notable passives
a special new left aligned window so you
can stay aware of your surroundings
while allocating skills
and you gain two passive skill points
per level you're also able to allocate
passive skills from any of the three
starting locations regardless of which
character class
you picked
we have created low-level versions of
around 50 iconic skill gems 20 support
gems and over 70 unique items
these realified items are appropriate
for low-level play and include quite a
few things that are usually only
available at substantially higher
character levels in the core game
the whole island has been improved we've
made the terrain more varied and
interesting
so that the fights feel different
depending on where they take place
you'll encounter flask troves which
provide charges for your flasks
these troves periodically replenish
themselves so expect a lot of combat to
occur around them
there are many other small improvements
you'll notice when you play real such as
an improved spectator mode improved
leaderboard and ability to pillage items
from players through a special interface
rather than having them clutter the
ground
[Music]
you don't need to delete and remake your
character for each game as you could
just reuse your old one which is
automatically reset to level 1.
your prize for coming first in a royal
event is this new road dinner hideout
decoration
it's a bit like a challenge league totem
as it grows more impressive as you win
more events
morale is available to play today as
soon as our q a session concludes then
about 45 minutes
so patreon path of excel client and when
we're done with the q a log in and click
to join the rail event on the bottom
right of the screen
for more detailed information on how the
mode works check out the news post we
just made on pathofexile.com
we'll be running the event from today
over the weekend if you don't get a
chance to play royale over the next few
days we'll run it again every weekend
other than expeditions launch weekend
for the next few months
please check it out and let us know your
feedback
keep an eye on our news over the next
week as we reveal the finer details of
what's coming in expedition including
the full patch notes on tuesday u.s time
we'll move on to the q a shortly to
answer your burning questions but first
let's have a look at the new supporter
packs that are available right now to
celebrate the launch of expedition
and help fund ongoing development of
path of exile path of xl2
and special modes like royale the
soulkeeper and acr supporter packs come
with masses of points to spend in the
store
social frames forum titles and badges a
download of the digital soundtrack and
of course
exclusive cosmetic microtransactions
like armor sets and weapon skins
the soul keeper series comes with an
exclusive pet in that ecs series an
exclusive set of wings
on top of the traditional small and
medium-sized supporter packs that are
consistent with ones we've released in
the past
we're also adding an optional new third
tier for each series
this new tier includes an exclusive
apparition portal effect and a slightly
better ratio of points per dollar spent
the introduction of these new packs
should give you more options for what
combination of each pack series you
purchase
like always it's possible to upgrade
between pack tiers within each series
thank you so much for your support
purchases of these supporter packs are
the only thing that funds the ongoing
development of path of exile
as well as expansions like expedition
and path of exile royale
the reveals we showed you today are
already live on youtube for you to link
to your friends in case they miss the
live stream
please do so we'd love to have as many
of you as possible joining our
expedition next week
it's time for the q a if you have any
questions from what we've shown you
today
please get them ready because i'm about
to be joined by ziggy d as we answer
your questions on twitch chat
and after that see you in royale
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning from australia new zealand
exiles i'm ziggy d
and i'm joined here with none other than
the chris
wilson good morning chris how's it going
hey things are going good
that was a a lot that was pretty spicy
set of uh
reveals there and yeah we've been
apprehensive about that one
yeah i imagine there might be a little
bit of nerves uh
nerves going into some of the uh nerfy
side of things i almost said it there in
fact
uh a lot some pretty big changes here
with flasks
and general balance and stuff like that
i imagine a little a little bit
uh make it a little bit nervous to
reveal
yeah we're pretty confident in the
changes though some of them been a long
time coming and
it's often the case that we'll have
something we want to do in a given
league and then push it both
because it's hard to rip the bandit off
and make nerfs and also because the more
we make at the same time the better we
can get the balance by balancing around
them simultaneously
yeah we'll get into the uh nerfs and
difficulty changes and floss and things
like that a little bit later but i
wanted to start off with some questions
about
expedition league the new league that's
been revealed
um i my first question is what sort of
failure states do these expeditions have
like if you die during the explosive
excavation process
does it fail or can you come straight
back into it it's pretty permissive um
you can come back in basically there's
no timers and no automatic failure
essentially as long as you've got enough
portals to get to the area then
it's um easy to come back and resume
whether you're placing explosives or
doing the combat part of it uh if you're
playing one of the expeditions that's
accessed through a logbook then it's got
six
portals um you know like a map does for
example so providing you haven't
depleted those you can come right back
i imagine with uh a different power
level for people to get used to that'll
be helpful
yes basically it's not like a hard
failure state lose things
a la heist or something like that in
this situation
are the logbooks the mappy system for
this
uh end game only or are they available
sooner oh they're available sooner they
kick in i think act three onwards so
you'll start to get them relatively soon
so that'll uh give me another thing
that'll make it take
a lot more time to get down cameras i
can just keep it
you know the temples of that swaddle of
course but you know they're fully
tradable so if you
don't want to play them or just want to
rush to maps you can always trade them
for some currency
you also added uh gheed gambles i'm just
gonna say i mean you
you touched on it with the 20-year
nostalgia um that's awesome
that's not a question though uh are
there any specific like new uniques or
items that we can only get through they
unidentified gambling with gwenon
or the other vendors i suppose so we
intentionally didn't put any items
exclusively
in those windows we didn't want it so
the players absolutely have to engage
with those systems to get those items
um but you can get some quite
interesting stuff like if you're lucky
for example while gambling for an item
you can get
influenced items for example you know
it's not just vanilla rares there's some
fun treasures hidden away there any uh
other things like
from other leagues like temple modifiers
or anything like that
or are you kind of sticking with the new
line of thinking of keeping those things
to their respective leagues
we are trying to keep rewards specific
for the content that generates them but
there's some interesting surprises that
people will discover when they're
doing their gambles all right i'm pretty
i'm pretty excited about the haggling
and the geek gambling
um now you mentioned uh immunity to
physical damage and i must admit i
cringed a little bit because i generally
dislike uh
immunities i've got questions about that
um as immunities effectively hard shut
down
specific builds um will these be easy to
avoid
you can choose where you place the
explosives and so you just absolutely
don't need to go anywhere near those
remnants if you'd rather go somewhere
else
and we prefer to have really hard
modifiers like this because either
immunity to physical is kind of going to
prevent you doing the encounter or it's
going to not affect you at all and it's
entirely upside to tag that one
and so because of this there's
interesting placement choices you'll
have to make
it's never going to be the case that you
know it's immunity to physical all
around you and the entire expedition is
a waste of time it's
relatively rare to get each one of these
um hard modifiers there
but um it'll mean that depending on your
build you're going to completely change
the strategy of how you place the
explosives
and it's worth noting that the remnants
really do ramp up the difficulty quite a
bit like it
you know players will see that they
provide benefits and think sweet i'll
just tag all of them and you should only
do that if you've really read what they
do and actually
feel you have a character capable of
doing that content which will be
slightly harder to achieve in this
league compared to previous ones
it sounds like you'll know if you hit
the wrong one you kind of touched on my
next question there a little bit
but why use something like immunities
than if it's effectively completely
avoid
or just do it because it's a free pass
because
if it doesn't have a large impact in
either direction on your character then
it doesn't really matter which one you
want to hit
and we want to avoid the situation where
every remnant averages out to it's a bit
harder and gives you a bit more items
we're making it so that you know it
actually has an impact on your character
just like how you care if a map you're
running as temp chains or not you know
people actually do read maps before
running them and that's a good thing
some people yeah concerning
they'll have to now good stuff um
we had a very good co-op league lastly
just want to say that ultimatum was
fantastic for co-op
uh how does this one work in co-op um i
believe that only the
map instance owner can actually place
the explosives but everything else is
everything else is cooperative you know
you can share the drops and share the
fighting and so it's really good to
bring a team for it especially with the
new difficulty um
it is basically the case that nowadays
when we're designing leagues we're not
going to
allow ourselves to release something
that works terribly in multiplayer like
it's a mistake we've made in the past
and
part of the process now is asking the
question how does this work with parties
to the point where we have some pretty
cool league ideas
they get put back on the drawing board
because they really aren't party
compatible
that's uh really good to hear i've very
much enjoyed the new trend towards
making things a lot more cop handy
uh does the currency stuff kind of like
spread out between the players like both
people get access to the trade windows
or
only if it's their map or how does that
work am i understanding i'm just going
to check this hey guys
all the players can access the vendors
right
yeah it's all good okay that's okay
so good nice
if it's not the case they'll fix it good
stuff
i feel like i'm winning the q a if i ask
you a question you have to look after
the side to
ask jonathan whoever is sitting next to
you i have people in the background
today's crowd is mark and rory hi
margaret rory
thanks guys uh next up i want to ask you
about some of the new skills normally i
leave the skill stuff a bit because
technical information is better read
when you when you reveal the gems a
little bit closer to release
but this time you have 19 skill gems one
for each ascendancy class that looks
like and that's
pretty huge and some of these are also
very interesting so uh
let's just rattle off some some of these
skills uh rage vortex it's limited to
one active at a time
and it looks pretty cool uh but does the
attack does this take attack speed into
consideration then since you can only
have one of them
yeah that's right if you have increased
attack speed it affects the speed that
your vortex attacks you can just imagine
it like a detached copy of yourself
psych learning basically right like it
spins off a copy of you doing a cyclone
and so this means that if you have
increased attack speed or various other
bits and pieces it will be acting like
you would do with cyclone yourself can
you ramp that in
i saw some of the concerns and chat with
like that clear speed look like it might
be an issue with it can you wrap that in
terms of aoe a fair bit
maybe with like melee range or something
like that yeah but here's the thing guys
when we're filming this footage we have
two choices we can film the low level
footage or we can film nuts in game
stuff
and so the team being how they are made
nuts and game
stuff we're talking pim tower characters
like as far as you can go right like
mirror worthy gear
and they have these builds that clear
the screen in seconds and the rage
vortex was you know the size of pluto it
was just ridiculous right
and so we filmed a bunch of footage and
it looked
really powerful the problem is if we
stick that as the first thing you see of
the skill you're going to assume cool
that's without support gems i'm going to
ramp this up
a lot and so we toned it really far down
for the
a lot of the footage you're seeing here
is intentionally completely unsupported
versions of the skills and you can see
the difference between the
like the vanilla one with almost monster
ai off really simple stuff
versus the higher level stuff and we
didn't go too crazy on the high level
stuff so yes
you can take these skills and really go
a bit further than we showed with them
it's always up to the players to min max
these ones i love when you mentioned
pluto because i knew the space nodes
were going to come out and chat and be
like
plato's actually small guys it's a
planetary body or an asteroid body even
if it's not a planet and it's still a
lot
that's still a large amount of area of
effect for a skill
right all right maybe it's not
technically planet-sized but
come on okay um
so with bone shatter the new stun
favorite
is there a limit to the trauma stacks uh
or is the limit just killing yourself
you will be dead long before you work
out with the limiters
[Laughter]
sounds like a challenge there's some big
thick armor
jugs out there i'm not gonna take that
one up i'm sure yeah i think the trauma
stacks drop off
um when they expire as well so you have
to be able to attack quite quickly to
find out if there's a limit
nice uh focus ballista seems to allow
you to greatly enhance your single
target by having
effectively two six links going at the
same time damaging the same target
will this just be like the new go-to for
boss killing setups then
well you already could have a second six
link for your totems that you were using
essentially like an existing
an existing ballista um this is a bit
stronger damage-wise of course because
um you're you know it's shooting faster
but one important note here is it's
going to stop shooting when you're
evading the boss abilities whereas an
existing totem would have just kept
blocking away at the boss
so there's pros and cons here but yeah
if you have the ability to shoot
uninterruption of the boss then this is
the way to ramp that damage up
um i was pretty excited about the reveal
of a grenade floss throwing skill
so does explosive concoction simply
consume
charges from ruby sapphire and topaz
floss to add more elemental damage
or are there some other impacts based on
the actual floss you have equipped
so by default it does fire damage and if
you have those special flasks equipped
it will consume some charges to add
damage if you're using the um the
lightning and cold ones
for the ruby flasks it doesn't add
additional damage it increases the
ignite chance and so you can really ramp
up your ignite build that way it already
does plenty of fire damage as it is
and this means that you'll need to
consider how you're rolling your flasks
of course you may want to roll so you've
got more charges available especially if
you plan to actually use those flasks to
stay alive
and so this build plays pretty
differently to other ones
is there any way to like scale the flask
effect usages of the skill
that's a good question how would you
answer that no it doesn't you don't
change
basically just how much
yeah the skill itself you don't change
how much it's consuming from the flasks
but of course because it consumes quite
a lot as you're using it you want to
make sure you have ample access
to charges whether they come from the
flask being better rolled or whether
they come from kill speed
um okay we've got a lot of it's a pretty
interesting one especially because it's
uh no weapons equipped can you have like
a shield equipped with that or
yeah i believe so as long as you're
unarmed okay um
the reaper skill the new summoning skill
looks extremely cool
uh but it's designed to be more of like
a single minion build which you talked
about a bit
um how is that able to compete with the
insane area coverage that you get with
minion swarm setups
basically just damaging the ability to
reflect bleed and control it better
it certainly has more safety issues for
your character if you only have a
limited number of minions but of course
in return you get to clear faster
potentially
it's worth noting noticing that you do
want to have a small swarm
so that you can feed people please not
discord call me things
um it's worth noting you definitely want
to have a small um
swarm so that you can feed the reaper um
she definitely likes to devour guys when
she's low on life and so
yeah it's quite important to have a few
other minions around
it seems like the sort of thing we can
have a bit of an active summoning set up
in addition to having that minion out
all the time and then
maybe supplement with that like i
imagine if it doesn't consume super
quickly um you could still have some
minions out on the field doing stuff as
well as getting
absolutely yeah and you can have minions
they're fine they're just weaker than
normal right so you just shouldn't go
all in on those minions
it's she'll grab them from time to time
whenever she wants buffs but if she's
low on life it's a lot more aggressive
in terms of how quickly she wants to
feed
chad was asking if they consume golems
but i'm pretty sure that's a yes because
it even consumes your own guardian as we
saw in the video
nice i like that um so eye of winter is
a skill that has been
a long time coming i think uh where
there's some specific challenges in
designing and balancing the skill
yeah this is an interesting one because
um
the the base version of this that we
were inspired by
is from a game that doesn't support
support gems and so
we had to be very careful when designing
the path of excel version to make sure
that it works well when you do crazy
stuff right and
the obvious question is what happens
with multiple projectiles and the answer
here is that the final blast of shards
is the one that gets the additional
projectiles that can shotgun right so
that's quite an interesting choice we
had to make
because you have the question of
shooting the eye into the boss and
having a lot of those shots at the boss
at the same time is very damaging and
that's one of the
the really iconic ways of using this
type of skill um the ability to aim that
correctly
now the true degeneracy comes from traps
minds totems unleash all that kind of
stuff right now you can have
some eyes on the screen let's just say
we designed this one for performance
okay um mana bond uh seems to mess
around with the concept of mana casters
does the bonus damage from the missing
mana scale up
as your maximum mana increases or is it
based on the percentage of missing
manner instead
of that it cares about the number of
points of missing mana so you want your
monopoly as big as possible and then you
want to have emptied it if you're
carrying about damage there
so for the area of effect increase it
cares about percentage missing and for
actual damage increase it cares about
numerical minor missing uh okay so the
damage scaling is still fits into the
kind of matter of manicasters that exist
currently
even though it kind of flips it on its
head a little bit conceptually
um let's move on to difficulty the big
stuff
uh what can we expect from behavioral
and balance changes where the specific
terminology mentioned there to monsters
in the campaign
there's a lot of stuff here and it's
kind of what happens if you go through
and redo stuff
you know in 2021 that you set up a long
time ago like you have to remember when
we first set up path of exile's early
acts
i mean it's had some maintenance since
then but we were children essentially
you know making our first game right
like we were in our early 20s have never
done one of these before
right yeah so it took some actual like
adult supervision now
for people you know like mark and rory
and stuff and what they're doing to go
through and make that content pretty
good
um so basically uh the monsters have
more life they move faster
they on average deal more damage per
second there's lots of aesthetic changes
you know a bit of like modern
let's make this stuff um not necessarily
like redo the art but in terms of making
skills and stuff like feel a lot better
than the monsters are using
and the ai ai's been redone for a lot of
monsters in terms of how intelligent
you know where they use skills there's
even some leading behavior where i think
hell rake will shoot as
glacial cascades out in front of where
you're running to trying to
tag you which is terrifying when it
happens to you and makes
yeah you really wonder what's happening
there um the monsters have a lot less
aggro range early on like it's less
a matter of aggroing the entire screen
when you run around so there are
improvements here to make the early game
actually
like appropriately simple in some ways
despite being deadly
um we had a look at monster density in
the first act we actually found that the
second half of act one had much lower
monster density than the first half so
we fixed that
um we've added some new monster types to
act one specifically in the prison in
mervel's caves so
yeah it does feel pretty different and
we kind of have a thing at the moment at
the office where we'll kind of dare team
members to just play through act one
i'll watch you
and it's it's fascinating to see the
results and so yeah they're
they're working through the other acts
um as fast as possible so that we don't
get too much of a jump between the two
types of content but basically the
intention is that
the campaign is actually a fun
experience to play through and for
for players concerned that that doesn't
add to their mapping experience
a yeah you can probably still use your
advanced poe skills to get to maps
quickly
like it's not that much of a speed bump
for the game to have some challenge
along the way you'll still get there in
hours it's fine
and secondly these changes do affect
maps a little bit the monsters will
start to become more intelligent and
a year later um maps will be quite a lot
more fun to play
because all the monsters will do
intelligent stuff
i quite like that you mentioned the
reduced aggro range is the thing so that
sounds like a trend towards
fighting fewer but more interesting and
tougher enemies which is something that
i've wanted to see for a long time so is
that a trend that we can see
expect to continue we want there to be
enough enemies that
it does feel like you're fighting pax of
course rather than just single super
intelligent guys
but at the same time you know there's no
need to spam monsters if we don't need
to right like it affects performance it
affects
a number of factors so we want the
fights to be about the right size
and we we haven't gone through and
reduced monster density and maps here
it's just making sure it's appropriate
for the campaign
it leads into the idea that i often talk
about stream which is
uh difficulty via like just a lot of
spammy stuff happening all at once or
difficulty that you can actually read
and engage with
yeah ultimatum versus say the boss fight
of ultimatum
right and this is something that we
worked very hard on with expeditions
combat because we looked back at
ultimatum and just said like
this is just throwing monsters at the
screen right like this is a case where
you kind of
close your eyes spam your clicks and
hope that you survive
whereas with expedition we want it so
that the monsters you're purposely
choosing the hard monsters you know a
bit like legion for example
and then you're actually able to
interact with them in combat with
telegraphed attacks and interesting
stuff going on
and so we think we've done a much better
job with combat in this league in fact
while in the video i explained that i
liked um the npc
mechanics with the merchant trading and
stuff honestly the actual
moment-to-moment combat of playing the
expeditions is a pressure breath of
fresh air compared to
um recent leaks that we've released it's
good to hear
uh what should we expect in terms of
other nerfs
that you haven't mentioned in the video
is there anything else
i think that it's better to wait for the
manifesto that we're going to be posting
about that stuff
um we didn't hold back
on the usual nerfs that we do there are
buffs as well
um it's just the usual balance pass but
one thing to bear in mind is because
there are so many core changes to path
of excel systems here we have been
relatively liberal with other nerfs that
we've needed to make like this is the
right time because the metagame is going
to be different
normally in a path of excel league
players will say okay i know i know all
the good builds
the question is whether these new
bleeding skills are the best build or
not
if they are the best build i'm playing
it if they're not the best build i'm
playing the one that i already like
and it's pretty understandable here you
don't know what the best builds are
we've nerfed the best builds we've
buffed the non-best builds
we've changed our flasks work in a very
large way the game plays differently
like you can't walk into this expansion
knowing what's going to be amazing
and that's going to be quite an
interesting process of discovery so the
number of viable builds both due to the
uncertainty and due to the fact that
they're actually more viable builds now
is going to be quite high so when you
see the manifesto and we'll do our best
to explain
the reasoning behind the divs we don't
want to do it arbitrarily like we
understand
that nerfing the game um will turn some
players off and it's generally seen as a
negative thing we would only do this
if we felt that it was the right thing
for path of exile both in the future and
immediately that's uh
that's a good lead into asking about
like so recent leagues have been pretty
nerf heavy in general with like fewer
buffs to underuse skills and builds
and while the goal is pretty clearly as
you started in the video to start
raining in power creep and up the
challenge of poe
we also expect some love for some of the
older things for people to get excited
about
oh yeah absolutely we've we've
definitely selected old skills that need
some work and
and buff them you know we've got a
growing list of those internally and as
the team discover more that are easy for
us to numerically change we do that and
i
i'm careful not to over promise here
because in the past we threw numbers
around of number of skills that were
buffed and then someone looks at a skill
kind of sideways and says
that's not really a buff so i'm not
going to name any numbers but yeah
there's a bunch of skills that we've
been working on and
you know it's it's going to continue
right if we see stuff that's below the
curve we'll make sure to adjust it
now one thing that's important to bear
in mind here is like when we're looking
at builds that have been popular
recently we're seeing like
ice spear spark burning arrow turning up
just out of nowhere because people find
clever ways to use them
and those are not skills that we said oh
yeah no one's using burning area let's
have 30
more damage or anything this is a case
of players saying oh there's a cool
combo
and then it starts to take off and so
there are a lot of sleeper skills there
that probably don't need buffs that are
just waiting for the right
moment to be found now of course there
are also ones that do need buffs and
we've been careful about those ones
how do you find managing the community
reaction to dealing with power creep
like this
it's it's difficult to communicate this
stuff because everyone who's watching
this can hear the explanation and it
makes sense but i don't expect all the
players to watch this
it's hard to actually have someone like
read the patch notes see a change to
their favorite skill that they know and
love and get excited to play that
particular release
because like it's it's what
the safe option in the back of the mind
is to play the thing we've just told
them
you're going to make 10 slower progress
playing that thing which
is fun in the context of a more balanced
game where now you're getting a better
ratio of rewards per time in various
other bits and pieces
um but it is difficult to communicate
this and it's so
it's so tempting to just play for player
expectations and throw entirely buffs
around and never touch anything nerf
wise you know we don't have to come into
work and nerf stuff if we wanted to just
be popular
and have record player numbers we would
just buff up and then the game would die
relatively quickly because there's no
actual challenge left we want to be the
action rpg that is that despite having
been out for a decade
still maintains some degree of a level
playing field and that requires
occasionally
we have to rip the band-aid off here now
it's been tempting to leave all of this
for path of xl2 launch day right like
you rock up to path of xl2 and the game
is entirely different
and that jeopardizes the launch date to
some extent we can find out now
how these things actually play we can
find out now what the reaction is going
to be
and make sure to have it in an
appropriate place by p2 launch day
and so this means like players if you
play this and you actually like two
weeks into it hate what we've done
you know post some constructive feedback
explain why you found other behavior
more fun
explain what you'd like to see in the
future and we will read it we do have
our own vision for what we're doing here
but at the same time
you know it's a game we're making for
you guys to enjoy and we believe that a
greater degree of skill
um variety being used and also some
uncertainty at league launch about what
the best
builds are are actually enjoyable things
because we see people complain
constantly including our own staff
that they already know how the league is
going to go because they know what build
they're going to play they kind of
understand how it's going to play out
and we want to create some mystery there
we want it so people are actually
pushing to find the best builds
that's a good time to ask like what is
do you have a specific
vision for difficulty that you'd like
the game to reach i know in the past
it was mentioned that ideally the game
would have periods of casual game play
with those spikes in difficulty is that
still the vision or has it kind of
changed over time
yeah that is the version we do want it
so you can play relatively safely and
then have spikes of difficulty
occasionally and this is what you'll see
when playing league content that we've
been releasing for the last few leagues
that content is fun when you're playing
through the various encounters the
problem is that the campaign and kind of
map content between the leagues can get
so much easier it's just so far under
the curve like we're having situations
where
when we're balancing the monsters for
like ritual or delirium or something
they were like
triple the hit points of regular game
monsters you know we're sitting there
doing correct balance for the new stuff
and the old stuff was languishing with
incorrect balance and that's why we've
been working to
raise it back up again and also to make
sure there's more consistent rewards and
so on so
it's worthwhile playing both types of
content
there's a couple of questions i have
here that have been picked up from chat
that
kind of touch on the same area of topic
which is how does this
how do you feel this impacts like uh a
player who maybe doesn't play as much
path of exile but
has in the past due to power creep being
able to access more content being able
to do shaper and elder and
have enjoyed that experience as a result
uh you're making
the game a lot harder overall in general
how do you feel like it affects those
players and how do you want it to affect
those players
well there's a couple of things here the
first one is that if you
wait a week read what the best build
guide is or what your favorite youtuber
who's worked out how to play the game
properly and do what that person did
you can probably still get similar
results right like we're not talking
about big nerfs here this isn't
the big difficulty change there could be
a big difficulty change in the future
this is the first step down that path
to see how it's received and how much
more fun it is and so on we're hoping
the response is
that it is actually more fun so it's
still going to be possible for casual
players to get to the end content
and then the second thing is
philosophically should there be content
that requires a lot of work than not
everyone can get to
right i'm not saying creating content
for the one percent i mean creating
content for the 15
um there are arguments that there should
be content that the character player
just can't see without significant time
investment
now of course it sucks if that's
something they were seeing without time
investment before and now you've taken
it away from them
but over time as we maintain the
difficulty in a good place any
new expansion content we add like at the
next endgame expansion for example maybe
that will be difficult enough that the
casual players may not get to see that
without a bunch of work
backing onto that question there's been
like content you've added that has been
tuned towards the power creep so like
new content difficult content
high end game bosses league content
stuff like that that is designed for
the level of power we had previously is
some of that stuff going to be
tuned we are we are making sure it's in
a good place balance wise a lot of it's
to do with how late into the league
people see it right like
let's say the league's out for three
months we're not saying it should take
90 days of grinding to get to some of
the content right that means people have
to like to sit at their computer for the
entire three months without a job which
is unreasonable
but at the same time is it okay that
people are killing the absolute end
bosses within
days of the league coming out right like
that
it feels it could take a little bit
longer now at the moment we're not
just extending that arbitrarily like
we're trying to make actual reasonable
balance changes to the game rather than
just saying oh this grind is twice as
long because we want people playing
longer you know that's a bit of a cheap
shot there but
we are looking at ways that we can make
sure that there's a lot more progression
before you reach
the end of the game and run out of stuff
to do chat
says yes it's fine that uh people reach
those bosses in the first few days but i
think that kind of like expands the
question out to
um is that more about like you know the
title killer killing the boss in the
first few days or is it more about
like the larger bulk of players killing
bosses in the first few days
whereas and people are living
vicariously through the top streamers
and stuff it is a question of whether or
not
you want your favorite good streamer to
take a bit of time you know whether you
want to race if you see what i mean like
these those events to
um you know to kill top bosses and so on
is that more fun if it takes a little
bit longer and
we haven't extended this particularly
large you know particularly large amount
it's more of a philosophical question
here but
we are trying to experiment with this in
ways that don't just punitively say to
players hey that thing you used to do
it's now just going to take longer
because we feel about it you know
there are no like experienced nerfs for
example on this expansion even though we
desperately want the race to 100 to take
what it used to do that's not a change
we're making um you know without careful
consideration and some upside to it
this is all kind of ramping towards like
having less of overt
jump to path of exile two's gameplay um
how do you like what happens if uh it
feels like it's going in the wrong
direction as you get towards path of
exile too how much
room is there to kind of like shift
things in a different direction do you
think
this is why we're doing it now right
path of exol 2 is at least at least a
number of leaks away and if we continue
this work rather than just kind of
sweeping it under the rug for later
which is what we were doing before
to some extent if we actually
proactively start this now we can get
the feedback and data that we need
to make sure it's in a good place
because we've been careful with path of
excel too
every system change we've made is an
improvement on here we want and the
content is great right there is no doubt
the path of xl2 is going to be
successful
the scary thing is where it comes
balance wise because we don't want to
launch it with the crazy tier of path of
exile balance that the game has evolved
to a power creep
and so this is our strategy of carefully
getting things into the right place
before poe 2 is released and so the
players have a good expectation of where
things are going and what they're going
to receive
um i want to get into flasks because
that's a huge topic
um so not only have flasks
like the flask issue effectively
contributed to play hand strain but
the design intention of the entire
system seems to have been lost over time
so it doesn't really seem like a very
easy thing to change though i have
because it has some really far-reaching
gameplay and balance implications and
intertwines with builds and all sorts of
other gameplay aspects
uh how much how do you think the
proposed changes are going to change the
moment-to-moment gameplay of path of
exile i think moment to moment you're
going to be less reliant on your flasks
like they have less
overall power contribution to your
character and your wrists will hurt less
i think
that's very good the uh i've got more
questions about that later but uh
does the new flash charge like gain
balance mean that we're like simply
forced to use our flask more
strategically as a result
you still get a lot of flash judges it
kind of shows how bad it was that we can
cut
map flash charge game by three quarters
and you still get plenty like
that was just to prevent it being
literally free to use your flasks
but ideally yeah ideally yes there'll be
a lot more strategy
especially if you choose using kindling
orbs because they really ramp your
flasks back up
to you know like where they were before
but in return you don't get flask
gain while the flask is active and so
that means you've got your kind of super
flasks that you're intentionally staffed
on charges and you can choose which ones
they are
how does this affect boss fights in the
fast charge game from boss fights or is
that left
unchanged so it will affect boss fights
that have adds you know if there's a
bunch of monsters being spawned they'll
grant less charges um
a lot of boss fights especially newer
ones don't really have ad waves like we
we give you flash charges during you
know cyrus fight phases and that hasn't
been changed that's about the same
if you want to have more uptime um or
power during
boss fights you can use in kindling orbs
if you feel that's necessary for your
build
this is something we've play tested like
you know maybe it's a bit harder but
harder with bosses is kind of the right
direction
i noticed that some of the utility flies
and specific have been uh
nerfed heavily like basalt flasks being
changed to give more armor instead of
mitigation
for any build now this whole change is a
bit counter to my expectations with this
systems change as i thought floss would
be kept fairly powerful
in effect but reduced heavily in uptime
so what led to this approach of making
the flask weaker as well
well there's two things going on here we
wanted more strategy and less spam and
we also wanted less overall flask power
like the intention here is not just
you know make flasks more interactive
and fun but also nerf flask power
now in this case because you're having
kindling orbs you can choose between the
uptime and power choice right like if
you want flasks that are weaker
that can be used quite frequently just
use them how they are like you get them
still quite a lot and if you want ones
that are impactful like before but you
use less frequently and more
strategically and kindling orbs can help
and of course instilling orbs let you
trigger on conditions where it's
necessary for that type of flask
but uh auto triggering a flask stuff
seemed pretty interesting
we get like a list of the sorts of
things that you can trigger on
yeah we'll put that together so it's
pretty cool there's some interesting
stuff there so there's like trigger on
adjacent flask use and various
interesting stuff like that
um as well as all the conditional ones
like we're not holding back on trigger
on bleed for example like all of the
things that you'll need to trigger on
are definitely there
this is something i thought of while
that was being discussed in the video
today only
but um why i make that like an item that
you craft randomly onto the flask i know
that's kind of path of exile style but
instead of having the auto flasking
thing be something you can set up
via like a menu or something like that
we don't see this as qol we see this is
a trade-off you're making economically
and for strategic reasons and it's not
too hard to find these right like it's
you know i mean you wouldn't set it up
on every flask throughout your gameplay
like it's an end game
thing and it does take you know a bit of
work to get your flask set up how they
are but it's like gcp anger flasks right
like no one is
complaining that it's too hard to
quality their flasks up it's the same
kind of thing it's about that much
effort
okay um did the uh
these new currencies going to be used on
unique floss as well um yeah unique
utility flasks
cool um so no life flasks for those auto
trigger
we would like the incandescent
installing orbs to work on life flasks
there are just some interesting
technical challenges and balance
challenges there so we haven't been
going nuts with like nerfs to how the
non-utility flasks are working here as
far as i'm aware at least
um and like this question's like if i
drink a life lost then i drink a
different life flask than a third one
the way that it internally deals with
those life game buffs is complicated so
when the
buff ends it's hard to say which buff is
ending when in various ways and so
triggering when the buff ends which is
one of our conditions
doesn't work particularly cleanly so
we've got some work to do there from a
technical point of view
and then if we're allowing auto
triggering and ramping of your life and
mata and hybrid flasks
we certainly want to do a balance pass
on those as well but that's a future
thing
okay um how will pathfinder work with
all of these changes
um it should be fine it should be fine
there's a um
the pathfinder is still very much
focused on you know
essentially the more you know strategic
flask um
usage we've not wanted to take away from
that particular build
will pathfinder still be fairly piano
flask oriented
they'll have the ability to to trigger
where it makes sense
so if you if your strategy was wait
until i'm um
got corrupted blood on me and then use
staunch you can of course
rely on the flask triggering
automatically if you choose to um
and at least if there is a piano element
to it for ideal play that's something
players are specifically choosing to do
by specifically saying out of the 19
ascendancies i want the one
which wants me to push the keys quickly
whereas currently one could argue that
all the builds benefit from
pushing the keys quickly okay so there's
a big round
i put a note here to warn that there's a
big ramble leading to this next question
so just be ready for that but um another
change that was mentioned was that
ailment and curse removal
will now have to be done reactively
rather than proactively
um and if say like a dousing flask is
used prior to being ignited it'll have
no one no effect so there's a bit to
unpack with this change i think
um reactive flasking could be a really
good thing for gameplay i feel like in
some cases for example you know you're
fighting a boss that ignites you so
you've got your finger hovering over the
floss to get ready to douse that ignite
and that
is like engaging gameplay effectively
however there's some cases in path of
exile where
this sort of change is potentially
concerning like for example you
cannot anticipate being frozen sometimes
when enemies have blanket added cold or
there's a mess of enemies ultimatum that
you cannot identify sources of potential
freeze from
so most players going to need to build
freeze immunity to avoid awkward and
unexpected freezing while mapping for
example
well there are a lot of options here
your first one is you can get an
installing orb to trigger on freeze if
you really don't want random freezers
then you set up your orb so that as soon
as you're frozen it unfreezes you right
the second option is good reaction times
right you forego having to do that and
instead when you're frozen you press the
button if that's how you want to play
then you've got alternate ways of doing
freeze mitigation there's also the
aquamarine um
flask now has an implicit property of
reducing
like chill effects or freeze effects on
you by 40 so that will you know
still allow you to perform actions and
so on and so there um
are several different ways you can deal
with this but at the end of the day if
it's a chance that monsters can freeze
you based on their properties then you
have to have some way of dealing with it
wait so the acro marine reduced freeze
effect that means you can still do stuff
while frozen it's just like
yes you can oh wow okay that's
unexpected
um so now that flask can only be used to
remove curses and not apply curse
immunity
is there any plans for curse maps
because curse maps i feel like were
pretty painful and
we mostly just were able to ignore the
problem due to curse immune flasks
so there are some new passive skills
which affect curses that you could
consider but basically we're wanting it
so that if you're playing a cursed map
rather than going curses get rid of it
you instead um think about what the
curse is actually doing and find some
way of mitigating that particular effect
on your character
this sounds like work but it's not
really that bad
okay um there's some balancing
changes prepared for or planned for uh
ailment immunity and stuff like that and
sources of those things
yeah um we do we have done some work on
element immunity when we actually had a
look at helmet immunity there and this
is covered in the nerfs and the
manifesto
there were quite a lot of very very very
powerful ways that just trivialized the
concept of having element immunity so
we've done some work there now it's a
more diverse set of things places have
to focus on which
is just one of the nerfs we're going to
have to discuss and um
you know learn to love together it seems
like something to expand upon in the
manner first so
yeah we just didn't want to turn this
into a three-hour round yeah honestly i
could talk about fast for hours so i'm
going to move on
no worries and we have royal informants
i know exactly i'm trying to
i'm trying to wrap myself with something
while they're playing
i'll be just over here playing a bit
reminder
i want to go play too but we might
overlap a little bit um so quality of
life and tech issues
can we expect a smoother launch and
queuing experience this time around oh i
really hope we can do we um we had
problems both of the last two launches
with stuff and we put a lot of effort
into fixing this so specifically um the
problem with queuing has been completely
sorted
the queue will be fast like it has been
in the past the issue that happened
before cannot occur again it is
literally removed from the source code
that is not going to occur the database
problems that we had um
at the last launch which interestingly
to do with
um page sizes in our character database
for the tech
guys out there get your page sizes right
in your databases
anyway um that is now good we should be
fine we've
put a lot of work into that so we're
expecting a very smooth launch from a
technical point of view and of course
we've learned
not to give paid streamers priority to
get into the game more quickly that was
a mistake and will not happen this time
um league box affinities was briefly
mentioned does this mean controller
clicking league items while in your
stash will automatically transfer
over to the league boxes and does that
apply retroactively to things like the
heist locker as well
yeah so we've enabled the affinity
system for both the expedition and heist
lockers um you just basically go to the
heist locker and turn on affinities just
like normal and then when you're in your
regular stash and you control like a
heist item it pops over there
so good ah much better um
so flash changes are a big step in
reducing player hand strain and
as tradition i'd like to also inquire as
to if there's any news on the progress
of improving item stacking
pickup radius things like that okay so
when we see on reddit someone will post
look at the amount of currency here and
they show a screenshot with an
absolutely unreasonable amount of
currency to pick up and we're like
what possibly can spawn that amount of
clicking this is ridiculous
like we look into it and we find for
example so the
atlas passive which enables king
harbingers right
so that creates up to four also king
harbingers on a map
and these dudes for some inexplicable
reason were spawning over
60 rare monsters for the fight right
which is completely unreasonable
each so there's hundreds of rare
monsters and then there's like a sextant
mod that says you get three currency
item drops per rare monster so you're
getting
literally multiple hundred currency item
drops it is completely reasonable
to say um why do i have to pick all the
stuff up and also completely reasonable
for us to fix that issue
so that particular one the king
harbinger one is one of the nerfs that
we're
doing here but to get to your actual
point though um our philosophy here is
where possible we will stack things
so that it's a couple of clicks if there
are a lot of items we don't want to have
it so you have to click 15 times
two is enough for that and the reason
why it is two rather than one is because
it is the concept of opening a trove of
stuff and getting multiple
piles of it out like it's representing
hundreds and hundreds of base items on
the ground
we're coalescing um breech splinters
together that was an example of
something where we realized there are
actually too many droppings so we're
going through and fixing this and as we
introduce new content
we make sure to stack that you'll notice
in the footage that we released today of
expedition
you're not really seeing more than two
of any particular type of currency
together
we've also had some interesting changes
to um
xbox drops we made them a lot better in
314 but we've gone through here and made
them a lot better again
in this patch we've coalesced items in
an interesting way where obviously with
like rares and uniques and stuff you
can't stack them
but we've basically said look we're
going to add a whole bunch to the rarity
so it skews more towards getting rare
and unique drops
and we're going to take away basically
all of the blue items and so now you're
getting far far far fewer like 50
60 percent fewer items from act boss
drops but they're just better than they
were before
and so this means that when you go and
kill kotava in the campaign and stuff
you'll get a much more reasonable small
pile of very good
items as opposed to an entire screen
full of junk to look through
any uh potential on like extending
pickup range or something there's a lot
of awkward situations where your
character has to move
that that moves the labels around and
things like that that make
the whole experience a lot less
comfortable even if there's not a lot of
items it can still be quite straining
nothing to talk about in 315 but this is
something we are very aware of
good stuff i will uh ask that question
every
q a no worries just track progress
just just interested just interested um
so now that we've done this uh new style
of league announcement live streams
uh a few times have you found them
compared to the old media tour method
uh we think it's we think it's a lot
better for a few reasons it's really
good to be able to talk directly to the
community and while we love the fact
that there were so many journalists
interested in explaining the information
to the players
we found a good compromise between still
letting journalists have some degree of
early access so they're posting their
articles as we speak
but also letting us directly phrase
stuff in a very specific way that poe
players will understand so there's no
room for misinterpretation
and it means that a talk like this isn't
just a supplementary thing it's the
primary way that people can find answers
to these questions
and it's been a lot of work putting
together these live streams i started
out working on it mostly myself but
quickly enlisted
um backs and various other people to
sort it out so bex has been primarily
pushing for the live stream content and
getting all the marketing stuff sorted
so
if people on reddit are wondering
wherebax has been the answer is very
very very busy
becoming a marketing manager essentially
she's been doing a
fantastic job with helping get this
stuff organized ahead of time the most
recognized human that i know in my life
so uh
beck's moving on up there with the uh
responsibilities and roles
we will make sure that she deserves she
stops in for some memes from time to
time so that people don't completely
miss her but um you know it's more a
matter of her chaining
training her army of juniors to make
sure that their meme game is
top-notch i was going to use the 100
emoji but i realized i'm talking so
nice 100 very good
uh that's that is awesome to hear very
well deserved for bex
um so we got a bunch of extra questions
that have been sprinkled in here from
chat as well so
i'm gonna start working through some of
these but you folks have fun in royal
once it's uh
up and uh running which sounds like any
moment now i think
it should it should be up i mean
assuming everyone behind me has done
their job right they should be playing
right now or there could be amazing
technical problems that i'm not aware of
myself but ignorance is bliss so throw
me some more questions
without seeing people sprinting in the
screen behind you and fire and smoking
you see fire yeah
um are there party cues available for
the royal game mode
uh no there aren't we we have an
experiment with some party stuff that
might be happening in the future but
um this is something we'd like to do
we're not philosophically against it
just for the time being it's solar
okay cool so potentially something to
explore in the future then
yeah we think it's a lot of fun we just
haven't got to it yet and it's partly
because it took so much work to get
right out of the state here like it's
literally 30 times the effort we put
into making the simple version
i'm really looking forward to checking
out after this uh will the expedition
detonation timers speed up in higher
level maps and instances
so this is a topic that even team
members of us have brought up where when
you push the plunger and there's this
cool thing where it goes and explodes
and it takes like three seconds and we
look at and go that's so cool and people
are going to be so unhappy at having
three seconds of their life wasted
and so we're looking at options to make
it um like to make the first explosion
quicker
now once that first explosion has
happened of course the other ones are
time to find because you have to
actually fight the monsters in each wave
like an abyss takes a little bit of time
to progress so
it's mostly the first one where we have
a cool visual feel for the theme right
now and we realize that is wasting three
seconds of combat so
we'll find a way of making that still
look good while being a bit more punchy
hopefully
i'm so glad to get those three seconds
back who am i kidding i was just gonna
waste them anyway
um so concerning difficulty what about
encountering the bosses
uh like the look at the chance for the
task master for example uh i think
that's asking about like what is the
chance to see the task master
is that an rng thing like we've had
sometimes in the past
so you find the bosses and those logbook
expeditions generally behind certain
objects like you'll find some passageway
or some fallen tree
or a hole in the ground or that kind of
thing and who knows what's going to be
in there maybe rewards maybe bosses and
i don't know what the odds are but i
mean my understanding is it's not meant
to be incredibly incredibly rare
do you guys want to weigh angel vaguely
on that
yeah you'll know if it's a boss chamber
you'll see it on the mini map when you
get in there
so you know that it's boss time but also
there's going to be an implicit on the
maps that says there will be a boss so
you
could trade for another player for the
bad boss so the map has
got an unpleasant model now but as you
see whether there's a boss there and
then once you're in the map it's clearly
much on the minimap so it's less of a
school secret that i was implying and
more direct which is probably what
you'll want can be a surprise but
there is also got it right so
it can be a surprise but you can also
explicitly trade for log books that have
the boss mentioned on them so if you
want to do bosses you can trade for that
and if you roll a boss and you're not
ready you can of course trade it away
nice thanks rory um
have you ever thought about creating an
in-game character creation tools like
the poe builder this also i guess might
be like
there was a thing briefly tested
actually that was like highlighting
this passive skill tree whatever
happened to that
there's this concept on the tencent
chinese realm about
these like recommended builds that they
have each season so when you log into
path of exile it gives you these three
beginner builds and you can choose them
and they kind of
they're kind of themed with various
sentences and you can
it recommends a variety of passives and
this is very much kind of
a choice that the chinese publishing
team have made that they feel is
appropriate for their player base the
way we've kind of evolved our community
with its build guides and so on works a
little differently in our opinion so we
haven't rushed to put that kind of
hand-holding for new players stuff in
there because there's other ways like
they can literally watch your videos to
find out how to play if you see what i
mean
so it's a little different and because
of that we have a system in there where
when you have a
recommended build loaded it highlights
the passive so basically this is this
way and they're marked in a certain way
and so we experimented with a system
where you can create your own
um like layouts that you can basically
flag passes by right clicking them or
whatever and then save these files and
potentially share them
and we have that implemented it's just a
bit janky and it needs some work and
we're not entirely
like we want to make a big thing out of
it if we're doing it so you can actually
share these and you have it so that if
you like
you go to someone's build guide and
there's a downloadable thing that you
get like an item filter
which then has the low level medium
level high level trees and it shows you
the correct order for allocating stuff
and that kind of thing
it hasn't been priority number one right
like in that amount of effort we can get
royal up or nerf most of the game right
like there's a lot of other things we
can be doing with our time so it hasn't
been
prioritized but yes it is something
we're aware that people want to do
um there's probably never going to be a
path for building level of um
build prediction like we while tools
like path of building are of course
incredibly useful we do want in the game
client people to actually have to like
kill the monsters to get their skills
rather than theory crafted and then be
done if you see what i mean
well just cracking me up so basically go
big or go home
on that one um yeah and it's just a
priorities issue like
we we can if there's enough demand for
having the ability to right click a
bunch of skills to lay out your builds
so that you don't forget what it is
and then share that with other players
let us know we'll get to it eventually
all right um we kind of touched on this
a little bit earlier but
this comment from chat's just so
hilarious so i'm going to read it anyway
will they make feared and awaken a 9
weaker
since they are gigger nerfing us to
oblivion
it's a good one um yeah we'll we'll see
we um
it's not gonna the nerfs aren't gonna
have that much impact on the time it
takes for people to get to that content
right like try it out it's not that bad
you'll find ways around it it's one of
those things in the past where you've
nerfed something we know something
massively and it's affected the players
by like two percent overall because
they're just smart and work out new ways
so basically no
to that person um can you apply empty
access to you on royal
royal characters and do they stay on
between games
when we enable mtx's we will find a way
that you can have your loadout so they
stay on
currently mtx's are not enabled in real
there are two reasons for that the first
one
is from a performance point of view
there's a lot of mdxs and there's a lot
of players and we don't want it so that
when you run onto the screen it slows
down or doesn't draw the other player
just because they're wearing a christmas
tree
and so that is something that we have to
sort out we're looking at ways i mean
the intention is of course i mean this
is an unmonetized game mode
mtx's are going to be a part of it but
for time being they're off so it's nice
and clean
um the other thing is from a fairness
point of view mdxs do let you hide what
your character is wearing and maybe this
is fine maybe you
learn that if you're covered you know
the guy's covered in fire and stuff you
can't really tell what he's doing
but we do need to stop and consider this
right this is a competitive mode we have
to make sure we understand the
implications
of enabling people to reskin their
characters in various ways
for example skill effects aren't that
misleading if someone uses an alternate
version of freezing pulse it's still
freezing poles and is recognizable
but by the same token if you cover
yourself in some complicated armor that
prevents you knowing if the person's
picked up a helmet yet
there might be some advantage there and
so we just want to have a stop and think
about that when we can
that's uh that's a really good point i
didn't think about actually like
potentially including the
we have a finishing die mtx that lets
you hide things so you could literally
pretend to be naked while wearing pretty
good items or uniques for example there
is certainly
um some degree of advantage that comes
from certain mtx's now maybe this is
irrelevant to the grand scheme i mean it
seems probably true for fortnite i don't
know i haven't played it but
you know we just want to make sure we do
the right thing there all right yeah
well it's good that you're thinking
about that because i didn't even think
about that
um will there be royale on consoles uh
no not at the moment and part of this is
just to do
with player populations and you know i'm
not trying to criticize the player
populations on console i'm just noting
that
only a portion of path of exile players
are choosing to engage in royal at any
one time
based on our existing data from the
first weekend we ran their 2018 version
and out of those players they're spread
across many geographical reasons if
you're in europe you're not going to
want to play against someone in
australia
and then there's time zones and then
there's the fact that most people
wanting to play royale in a royal game
currently
the matchmaking will just take far far
far too long to actually get games to
trigger
plus there's some work actually getting
it to work on console so for the time
being we're running it on pc we'll see
how it does and if there's the player
population to support some form of royal
on consoles we will absolutely bring it
there we have no problem
with bringing it there philosophically
we're not being blocked by the
publishers bringing it there it's
entirely a matter of it'll be super
frustrating if you try to join a game
and they happen to be eight other people
in australia interested at the moment
and that's not enough to trigger it
um is there any uh updates on how path
of exile mobile's going as well
how developed along yeah we decided not
to show any stuff yet and that's partly
because we um
want to ramp up the marketing towards
its release as opposed to dump all the
information on you now and then find out
how to change it
we um do have some cool stuff to show um
there's
you know the game's got its own
storyline and various other interesting
things that are coming along but we're
not really ready to actually show it off
just yet
um if people doubt that it exists they
should chat to the guys at xfalcon who
spent several hours playing it and get
some reassurances that there was
something there
awesome are there any planned atlas
changes this week
uh not this league i mean it's probably
a pile of nerfs just for expectations
but um
i say that without actually knowing
that's a joke um
the guys are smiling um but we do we do
have a you know annual endgame expansion
coming in the foreseeable future that
will probably contain more
atlas stuff as people know to expect
uh can you please ask if it is possible
for any character to find the winding
pier
going straight to the source for that
one can't comment on that
if i get banned from my own game it's
going to be a big problem
that would be a big problem it even goes
that high
wow yeah i had a couple of notes by the
way while we're talking to throw in
there well we still have literally
so the first the first one was we
changed how spectral helix works after
we filmed all that footage so i lied to
you um
so what you saw there it's very
interesting watching chat we show
spectral helix
and people are like that looks cool and
then it shows it with multi-approach
where it looks really janky
and people say that looks bad it's
amazing looking at the chiff between the
two
um we changed our multi-project effects
set previously it just caused you to
throw multiple projectiles at the same
time creating this
thing that a was just bad for balance
reasons bad technically and looked bad
we've changed it now so that a it does
more damage right
and b the multiple projectiles cause
more terrain bounces which actually
happens quite a lot because there's
occlusions everywhere
and so the skill works a little bit
differently and does more damage than
the version we were previously working
with and this is just due to the nature
of us working on stuff for 13 weeks and
having to prepare the marketing
materials a few weeks out you know they
can change
if it needs to so spectral helix is now
in my opinion a lot better i actually
kind of hated the way that multi-project
worked with it and
cringed a bit when putting together that
footage but i'm happy now
and um the other thing is we talked
about nerfing all the support gems
they're damaging ones right
and we did that wasn't a lie but what we
forgot to mention was that we've also
buffed melee skills quite a lot to
compensate for the fact that they were
really gutted by the support gem nerfs
so they're having quite a lot of melee
skill buffs to counteract a lot of the
um
nerfing there now it's worth noting
we're not trying to buff melee skills
in general above where they were before
there may be specific buffs to specific
skills
but the support gem nerfing which was
hitting melee skills particularly badly
has resulted in some melee buffs
on the other hand the spells in in
general are not buffed
above where they were before or anything
like that you know there may be specific
spell buffs of course
that seems fair
um so a lot of us who have
watched all of these q and a's and read
your manifestos in the past we know the
answer to the question of trade
like because it's already been discussed
to death in the past but
a lot of people who haven't seen those
before we get frustrated with them for
asking the question
are asking about trade so could we just
very quickly get a
brief summary on uh trade changes
things like that we don't have any trade
changes coming in this particular
update here there are two things to note
with trade the first one is if there are
things we can do that improve the
trading experience that are small and
prevent frustration we'll probably work
on those over time right we're not
opposed to the idea of
making trade um less frustrating we're
very careful though
that currently trade is both critically
important to path of exile's success
like we're not one of those games that
doesn't allow player trade it's so good
that you can find an item and it has
value you can actually trade it with
other people and like feel like it's the
thing that you have and you own
but on the other hand trade is directly
causing players to play the game for
less time and have less fun
like player the retention is so much
better in solo self-found you get on
average like 10 times as many item
upgrades per character slot
when you actually have to go and find
the items yourself and so we know that
if we made trade very easy
which we could we could in a few days
make it so you literally type in the id
and click it you've got the item
and then there's no real need to play
the game beyond a couple of upgrades to
your character i'm already seeing a bit
of that with players being able to
efficiently max out their character
and so it also in that case like
combined with rmt someone sticks some
money in and before you've even found
and banned the responsible people
they've got a max style character and
had that fun for the league
it's not a particularly good situation
and so philosophically we want to make
sure that trade is possible in part of
excel
but it is not particularly streamlined
because if it's particularly streamlined
people will just max out their
characters quickly and we think it's
good that playing the game to get items
is
an important um alternative now
the item system in terms of like the
amount of spam of rares and various
other bits and pieces in the game isn't
in a perfect state right like
we get this work that he's happening
there and so we're focusing on getting
that work done
so that the game itself is as compelling
and rewarding as possible
before we even consider any changes to
the trade system
it's also worth noting that for those
who look at the console or chinese
versions they have to trade market
and say we really want that bear in mind
that those players are looking at the
system on
the path of excel trade side and saying
we really want that one instead so there
are pros and cons to both systems
um and we do not intend to merge the two
together to make an instant trade kind
of thing
yeah it seems like our trade system is
more powerful overall in terms of
actually finding items just theirs is
like more
built into the actual game client it
this has the ability to make offers and
have them accepted without having to
meet anyone if you see what i mean
um which has its advantages but it's
basically the difference between
easy item finding versus easy item
trading if you see
and so with with our system it's a real
pain too like it's easy to find exactly
the thing you want but there's a real
pain to negotiate with the person and
learn to speak russian and deal with all
of the issues of getting the item
learn to speak russian i'd be dope if i
learned to speak russian from my blank
pwe
i think excel is an educational
experience
excellent um is there any like have
plans so
quite a long time ago you mentioned that
trade cross instance trading was a plan
but it seemed like that stopped being a
plan is that still the case
that stops being a plan at the moment we
realized that making trade easier in
that way was probably the wrong
direction
and um our vision of course in the
future involves
a better item situation than there is
now but we're working towards that the
way we feel we should rather than
like honestly if we if we if we made the
trade easier i think it would be the
death of the game and i know that sounds
dramatic but it's
we've watched this kind of thing happen
in other places and we're very very
careful with this like
we design path of exile to be a thing
that still exists when you people are
old like the goal here is you started
playing this in your 20s and you will
still be playing this in your 70s and we
will find a way of supporting that
and that involves not accidentally
giving in to things that we really
really feel the game shouldn't have
i hope our quality of life keeps ramping
then so that when i'm 70 i'm
still feeling fresh and spry in the
fingers and hands department
the flash changes in this patch will
help keep your wrists for a good good
few years
still good good to hear because i plan
on playing a lot this league start
um so uh someone wants to know
there's that's a long question
summarizing uh how how's hardcore gonna
feel and this difficulty
changes basically they're gonna have
more fun than before
i know that's kind of like the answer
isn't it it's like it's
hardcore if hardcore is just standard
with occasional annoying deaths
that's not fun if hardcore is an
achievement we're like i got a hardcore
in 315. i you know i got to maps some
315 hardcore which was actually a
mission
that's more fun right like it's getting
getting to maps being an accomplishment
is better bragging rights for people who
are choosing that mode for bragging
rights and adrenaline
you know we could argue that there's a
vision for an even harder hardcore mode
at some stage in the future that kind of
thing you know with ultimate bringing us
like i mentioned blant is like a regular
league for example that kind of thing
i'm sure there'll be players who would
enjoy that
um is there uh any performance
texturey plans or changes
people can expect to read about more in
patch notes and stuff like that
we deployed a lot of this stuff in a
engine patch a week or two ago
which has gone pretty well there's other
bits and pieces we want to fix based on
people's feedback from an engine patch
but overall we're trying very hard to
not have performance surprises on launch
day
um in addition various issues with like
invisible monsters and stuff at last
launch are pretty resolved now
we have that that particular thing was a
bug in the engine combined with an
incomplete shader gather which we've
worked out how and why both occurred and
fixed them
so i expect your bosses will actually do
attacks you can see in this particular
launch
fantastic chris thank you so much for
hanging out with us today and answering
a lot of questions you're welcome
i'm gonna go get ready to play some
battle royale i'm gonna refresh shred it
cry for a bit and then go play the
battle royale as well
it's uh it honestly it's all pretty
exciting there's
a lot here and i'm pretty interested in
seeing how
big changes pan out the fact that you're
willing to make big changes is
scary and i mean you can always you can
always walk it back a bit if you go too
far i suppose i
yeah we'll see how it goes but i'm
pretty confident and yeah we put a bunch
of work into making sure it's the right
stuff but
everyone have a great time with
expedition league it's a lot of fun good
luck with all of those skills um there's
a lot of new league starters to try out
thanks so much see you guys later
see you later
[Music]
you